こんにちははじめ社長です
今日は
税経を連れてきました
安心してくださいと白いマネージャーさんがいらっしゃい今日はよろしくお願いします
私疑問に思ったことが一つあるんですけどもアニメとかで美少女が食パン靴に加えて
いけな1個口くっている
筋子とぎゃっう使って運命的な出会い少しあると思うんですよありますあれ現実に起き
たらみんな運命を感じでに架ける鉄
あると思いましたが今日はその運命的な泥をする受益なくとして来ていただきました
よろしくお願いしますお願いします
[音楽]
男子ってだけでしょそうだと思うんですよまあスカートとかそういう場所で曲がり角で
そんなって清水とぷっ使ってキャー
大丈夫ですかなってるから全然運命的なそうです絶対好きになっちゃうよ
[笑い]
[音楽]
ブーバーありけど一間
ん
供与体と言われて現場にしました何処のかっカードです
ありがとうございます
あっ
レ軍
はいん
[音楽]
いいかんでる多分恋に落ちると思う後ちょっと大丈夫ですかみたいなちょっと顔色行く
感じくらい入っちゃっても行きません
あなたは湿度やだ
そんな感じでもお勧めします
1回僕が実験で受けてみようと思いこのれ落とせたらもたりしたもんだよ
goo
ん
[音楽]
俺の名前は中野第一27歳最近太ってきてで日でも言われたけど最近を痩せてきてるん
だ
今日も天気が良いあるが俺を呼んでるぜ何かで相馬ねーかなー
ですかは
4日
[音楽]
美少女が好きなのでまぁ美女税経にあずとも使いなく反応するはずです話してこの一瞬
で声を落とすことは可能なのでしょうか
ございました
びっくりしたしの円滑化と
俺の場合は次た傭兵富山県出身
最近は女の子との泥がなくて人会結構無駄な人がうわーうわー
てるぞえっ
ん
えっ何言っん
[音楽]
俺の名前は菅3月映像学院大学の3年生
なんか恋愛とかねえかなああああぁわぁ
[音楽]
その時彼の顔には俺が今まで見たことのないような映画をが広がっていた
これが恋の顔である
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
[笑い]
とった
それ
ん
作ろうじゃなくて
あー髪を